Do you know where you are right now?
I'm in a drug trial.
What do you think is wrong with you?
I'm sick... and I don't matter.
What would you say this trial is showing you about yourself?
Is this therapy now?
It's not therapy.
It's science.
Once you begin to appreciate the structure of the mind,
there's no reason to believe that anything about us can't be changed.
Pain can be destroyed.
The mind can be solved.
How many of your subjects have ended up catatonic?
Zero... roughly.
My head doesn't work right. I thought maybe these people could fix me.
Sounds stupid.
That doesn't sound stupid to me.
Okay people, let's begin.
In five, four, three, two, one.
My mind is playing tricks.
This is some multi reality brain magic shit.
I don't know what's real and what's not.
Something's wrong. What did you do?
Come on, wake up!
Every time I separate them they just find their way back together.
You are not protecting those people in there!